[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign the content of this program is
to provide nutritional education only
this program is not meant to take the
place of your primary care physician the
FDA requires us to let you know that our
products are not meant to treat prevent
diagnose or cure any diseases as an
empowered individual you have options
available we are honored to have one of
the founding fathers of epigenetics here
to guide us with the best options to
obtain or maintain Optimal Health Dr
Joel Wallach welcome to daily with Doc
and Becca
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
the content of this program is to
provide nutritional education only this
program is not meant to take the place
of your primary care physician the FDA
requires us to let you know that our
products are not meant to treat prevent
diagnose or cure any diseases as an
empowered individual you have options
available we are honored to have one of
the founding fathers of epigenetics here
to guide us with the best options to
obtain or maintain Optimal Health Dr
Joel Wallach welcome to daily with Doc
and Becca
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
the content of this program is to
provide nutritional education only this
program is not meant to take the place
of your primary care physician the FDA
requires us to let you know that our
products are not meant to treat prevent
diagnose or cure any diseases as an
empowered individual you have options
available we are honored to have one of
the founding fathers of epigenetics here
to guide us with the best options to
obtain or maintain Optimal Health Dr
Joel Wallach welcome to daily with Doc
and Becca body welcome welcome welcome
to daily with Doc so excited to have you
all here with us I love seeing new faces
and familiar faces and names as well I
encourage you if you are watching us on
one of our live streams
go to daily with
doczoom.com that's all together dealing
with Doc
zoom.com and join us here on our live
daily with Doc Zoom now
somewhere
we have
okay I think we got it awesome
my name is Becca dukes and as the
hostess of daily with Doc I I welcome
you
if you found this program on your own
then we are here for you if not get back
with the person that shared this program
with you because they cared enough to do
so
we have this program sponsored by
dailywithdoc.com where we provide a
store we provide all the replays we even
provide a 15-minute consultation if you
are not working with a consultant or a
distributor already if you are get back
with them and let them know that you are
interested in getting a consult because
it's very possible that a certified
holistic health coach is the one who
brought you to this program so that you
also can receive empowering information
on what you can do all on your own now
if you're on live with us and you would
like to ask a question make sure that
you find that raise hand option in the
zoom menu and we will be calling on you
in order in which your hand was raised
also make sure that you have the chat
turned on because
oh hi
with the chat then you will be able to
follow along with our co-hosts who are
putting information into that chat that
kind of just gives like a summary of
some of the things that are being spoken
about it also spells things out for you
so that you'll have an easier time
finding them or asking about them
whenever you do speak with an Associate
now Dr Wallach is just a gem he's a
national Treasurer who has a national
treasure in the Smithsonian Museum now
this National Treasure is packed full
with information through autopsies and
comparisons on nutrition and how it
affects a living being
Dr Wallach
in this book that's like more than a
thousand pages
yeah
five thousand five thousand yeah it
represents 32 well excuse me over 20 000
autopsies
so over 20 000 autopsies that are
represented in this National Treasure
and that is
exotic animals tell me the full diseases
of exotic animals thank you very much
diseases of exotic animals which I'm
really excited Dr Wallach because you
have somebody that is taking those
different chapters
and making them available to the public
no they're the raw notes they're not
actually just repeating the chapter
they're taking the wrong notes and
republishing them
um and it's really a great thing
the first one of course is primates
and that's why I made my very first
classic Discovery
um where I found the first non-human
case of cystic fibrosis at the Yorkies
primate Center uh when I was working
with NASA as a pathologist and
um
and I didn't tell them the slides I was
standing around were from a monkey I
just these are slides of the tissue
biopsies okay I was at the autopsy
and I sent them to five medical schools
and I said I think these tissue slides
are from a physical brosis patient what
do you think and all these medical
schools have came back and their
letterheads and said this is a classic
example of physical fibrosis and I sent
back in the letter to them I remember
we're talking 1976.
to send back a letter to them saying
okay great this is the first non-human
case of cystic fibrosis and I believe we
have you know can create a laboratory
animal
um
um set up here
um with these
animals are related okay and we'll have
um we'll have the um
uh
animals potential groups well there'll
be actually
um animals we can do studies on
study animals that will have the disease
and I didn't tell them I didn't think it
was genetic but so I asked permission to
do biopsies on the other 24 baby monkeys
in that Colony about the same age they
all had different mothers and fathers
they were not related other than they
were monkeys and they're all getting
groomed to go to space and so they
allowed me to do biopsies of them and
they all had cerebral roses
and that was it for me I said okay so I
I did my due diligence and I went back
and talked to the people who were
feeding the mothers and fathers and
cleaning up the cages and buying the
food farm and everything it turns out
the two people who were who were feeding
him every day were PhD
biologist and they believed very heavily
in in genetics and they
um were really upset
um by this because every one of the
every one of those baby monkeys every
one of the 24 baby monkeys had scissor
brosis
okay so I said what are you feeding them
well the fathers were picking on the
mothers and so what we did was we took
away their monkey pellets
which had all the vitamins minerals in
it we just gave them bananas and berries
and apples and things like that
so that you know they're busy eating as
opposed to picking on each other
and so that's why we had all those
babies with physical brosis and so I got
ready for publication and presenting at
a big National event for the National
Institutes of Health
and they fired me
they said well here you must be drinking
enough or something like that there's
something wrong with you this is a
classic example of a genetic disease and
you're saying it's not genetic well I I
know why it happened you know what it's
in my paper no you're done they fired me
and that's when I started going to all
these trade shows and looking for some
place and I didn't know much about
naturopathic medicine but I I did find
because they were looking for a
professor at MCN which is a Nature
Valley College of naturopathic medicine
up in Portland Oregon so I I took that
job to teach and I said you know why
don't I go to become a naturopathic
doctor and some I started taking courses
and in 1982 I became a naturopathic
doctor as well so I had my degree in
my BS degree in agriculture and soils
and
um that sort of stuff and then also I
had my degree in veterinary medicine and
now is going to have my degree in
naturopathic medicine and so that's kind
of exciting
that's very exciting but I want to back
up just a little bit Dr Wallach okay so
the males were picking on the females
yes so they took away their palettes and
just gave them fruits and vegetables or
just fruits so they were basic fruits
and berries
Bruce and berries so they were basically
nutritionally starved so they were busy
and occupied eating and eating eating
instead of picking on each other that's
correct and then the behavior is for
happy see we told you they're not
picking on each other now
well hey if somebody's bored or they're
starved and they just eat that doesn't
give them time to do anything else right
well and of course the berries and the
fruit didn't have all the nutrients in
there that were necessary to prevent
physical brosis and so I did a lot of
studies on that and you know looked at
um article has been written over the
years and came to a conclusion I thought
I knew what it was and sure enough I was
correct
and so
that started me on that track
well starting on that track Dr Wallach
has also been documented in another book
share with us a little bit about this
book right here oh okay Revolution
well that's that's the latest book and
it says 75-year uh track record of my
findings and research and so forth and
some of some of the more what should I
say breakthrough findings
and
um it's one of those things where
um it goes back to when I first
discovered
um the fact that
um we needed nutrition I was nine years
old and they were going to send me to
um an experimental hospital for people
who are violent and I was very violent I
was only nine years old very strong
because I'm throwing bales of hay on the
farm
and I'm sitting on the bed on a Friday
night and my parents are packing my
clothes because they're going to put me
in the hospital on Monday
and I said well when am I going to get
out of the hospital I said well you may
never get out you may be in this
hospital for the rest of your life well
that didn't make me happy so the next
morning on Saturday
um I realized that there was something
going on here that even the doctors
didn't know what was going on because I
had seen 20 different doctors in five
years I'm only nine years old I've seen
psychiatrists I had seen pediatricians
I'd seen pediatric psychiatrists and not
one of the 20 doctors could figure out
what was going on they didn't have a
name for it back then today it's called
Tourette's Syndrome okay and so on
Saturday morning they're starting to fix
breakfast in the house and so I took my
my um
um cereals you know my Wheaties my
breakfast of champions I took my oatmeal
uh out to the chickens and I went to the
barn I got the Alfalfa Palace that were
supplemented with vitamins and minerals
we feed the calves took them back to the
house put them in my cereal bowl put
milk on them had them for my cereal on
Saturday morning Sunday morning Monday
morning and bye 2 30 in the afternoon on
Monday afternoon I'm cured
after five years of spiraling downhill
so I knew there was something really
crazy there and that got me going uh on
the path that I'm still going on and so
anyway to make a long story short
um we've I've done
gosh I don't even know how many papers
I've written now it's hundreds and
hundreds of papers and hundreds and
hundreds of CDs and books and DVDs and
things and and
um autopsies
32 000 mostly I'd say um 75 percent were
animals 450 different species and the
rest were humans and the whole idea was
to determine where we went wrong in
creating these diseases because none of
them were genetic none were on immune
and
my great Attorney John is nimord and I
we sued the FDA
in federal court on that one subject
eight times we prevailed every time and
that was to get bottoms and middles and
baby formulas because of the cystic
fibrosis and then I also got registered
got rid of mustard dyspeed that's a long
story that'll be another day I got rid
of my security this fee and Jerry Lewis
was happy about that and the Monsters
Association fired Jerry Lewis and shut
off his Telethon even though he'd raised
2.6 billion dollars for them over 46
years
um because there I don't know if they
really wanted to find a cure but we
found the Cure and they fired him for
saying we found the Cure and the
treatment and prevention
and then
um
and then I'll see here after that
uh I started again by doing more
teaching and starting a practice you
know in 1982 became an age-related
doctors and started seeing people and
got into radio and TV and stuff like
that because I I wasn't seeing but just
to have a dozen to a dozen patients a
day my practice in Portland Oregon and
so I realized I had a lot of information
I needed to see more people to get that
information out there and to make a long
story short
now this book goes through much of my
major findings and we had a lot of what
should I say support and help from
famous people like Pat Boone uh he great
great singer and Entertainer and movie
star and he
um
wrote the forwards to the book I mean
it's really great for and he tells a
story of him and how I helped him and
how I helped
um let's see here uh
the guy who is the mayor of
um Andy Young
Andy young yeah and also he was the uh
he was the um guy who represented the
United States as as an ambassador to the
United Nations and he was going to have
a double knee replacement and I rebuilt
his knees so he didn't have to do that
so that story is in there and then in
the end of the book the stories there's
more stories like that from Danny Glover
a great great great movie star and
comedian okay and so he he had his
stories his own personal stories plus
stories of other people who he'd help
with my information
because he was excited about it and so
then
to make the book
affordable for everybody because this is
going to be a 3000 page book if it's
going to be something crazy
um I haven't there's 20 chapters in
there I believe and then we put a
summary of each chapter at the end
with uh the books that have the Salient
information on major discoveries in that
chapter the books and the CDs and DVDs
and the references so as opposed to uh
you know like like the Encyclopedia
Britannica where you can buy this you
know dozens of books and everything you
get thousands of pages and they have all
these thousands of references you have
that stuff
but
um it's in in such a way that if you
want to just order one of the reference
books or two or three of the CDs or
something like that you can do it okay
so it's not going to be outrageously
expensive for the average person and so
I'm very excited about this book is
slowly sort of slowly sort of gaining
some traction uh because the format is
quite different and in the back when I
talk about all these various other books
was already that are already published
and have great references and so forth
and pictures
um there's a you know a picture of the
cover of those books and a little you
know like a paragraph on what each book
covers and so forth it's a little bit of
a different reference than just the
author's name and the name entitled the
book
yeah as I was looking through this
doctor while like I mean it goes chapter
10 and then the interview with Dr Joel
Wallach January 10th
in Clinton Maryland I mean Nate's pretty
a little bit more than what you know a
biography normally would show that's for
sure
so yeah and that's just one example all
the different books that are referenced
that you've written others have written
that
it supports
what you have done and what you are
saying including Pages look like this
with those oh hey I I know what those
pages are
that took a lot of time yeah
so what Dr Wallach is pointing out in
the back of the Wallach Revolution
there is our informational brochure from
drj Wallach it has
all of except for the ones that are
being released
you know next month has all of the video
or the videos the DVDs the audio the
books
that Dr Wallach and Dr Milan have
published plus some of their friends who
have also published some books and it
also includes the introduction of our
bundles
so for those of you who have been
listening to Dr Wallach in the past or
even in the future now
and he talks about the quartet of books
for the quintet of books
and for those of you who are involved in
our health coach certification course we
even have a health coach bundle that is
going to be available that will allow
you to get the books that are
recommended in The Institute of holistic
health health coach certification course
as a bundle with a discount so folks if
you're interested in more about that
health coach certification course go to
coachwith Becca that will take you to my
site that gives information on that
program if you're working with somebody
get back with them and ask them if they
know anything about it because we want
to make sure that the person that shared
this program with you gets the credit
for that as well
well Dr Wallach
I have something that I need to read
really quick
and as soon as I get here
all right it says the content of this
program is to provide nutritional
education only the program is not meant
to take the place of your primary care
physician the FDA requires us to let you
know that our products are not meant to
treat prevent diagnose or cure any
diseases as an empowered individual you
do have options available and we are
honored to help one of the founding
fathers of the science of epigenetics
here to guide us with the best options
to obtain or maintain
Optimal Health
Dr Joel Wallach
Dr Wallach you were just holding up
epigenetics that's one of my favorite
books well it's a summary of my
autopsies on that 25 million dollar
grant that got me the diseases of exotic
animals and all my work in the
Smithsonian Institute
and so that book epigenetics sells for
25 bucks each I think something like
that give or take a little bit but um
everybody can afford that whereas the
disease of exotic animals knew in the
Box still in rapper has never been
opened they sell for 25
000 each okay WV Saunders was the
original publisher biggest Publishing
House in the world they were the
original Publishers and they sold the
rights to another company
and
um that
um
uh book now you go to Siri and answer if
there's any used copies available and
they have them you know where they've
been riding in the margins and the
corners of the pages are dog-eared and
everything like that and on the average
you can find them any day at like 3 500
to 5 000 each
but if they're really beat up you can
get them for 1500 or something like that
you know the dog peed on them
oh you didn't have to go there
so I'm going to go to a happier note
doctor while like and we are officially
today daily on daily with Doc on YouTube
and we have many many people watching
and we have people that are commenting
on YouTube also and that happier thought
that I'm going to it says greetings from
beautiful BC Canada you two magnificent
beings that was so sweet thank you Don
and then John says I always enjoy the
information that you both provide and
take and utilize most of the youngevity
products and am a very healthy 72 year
old thank you both and Ben for sharing
your knowledge so that is pharmacist Ben
that John is referring to so I love that
and Heather says this is awesome it's
nice to see daily with Doc on YouTube so
I think it is too Dr Wallach well thank
you I know it took some effort to get
all that done so we appreciate all that
effort and the main thing is is getting
that information out there to more and
more people and that's the whole goal of
the whole thing is to save as many as we
can
yes it is yes it is and Brenda puts in
the comments here live with us she says
I am reading that book and halfway done
referring to epigenetics so thank you
for sharing that absolutely thank you
thank you well Dr Wallach we have many
many questions and folks if you're on
live with us
don't forget to raise your hand if you
have a question that you would like to
ask of Dr Wallach the first question
that I'm going to go to though is from
Nicole so Nicole has a client that she
is working with Dr Wallach and this
gentleman is 69 years old
178 at six foot tall
he is
he's struggling with military PTSD Dr
Wallach which my heart goes out to all
those that are in the military and have
seen
um so much that many of us will never
have to because of you thank you for
your service to everyone that's on here
and watching and listening
um in addition to the PTSD Dr Wallach he
has blood pressure concerns
he is on a medication for blood pressure
and
he's wanting he's wanting some
information that will help him with the
depression that comes with the PTSD the
anxiety that comes with the PTSD and of
course blood pressure yes he does still
have his gallbladder he only wakes up
maybe once during the night to go to the
restroom
okay yeah that's that's what I've got
okay well thank you that's good
appreciate that all right so
um
he needs to get rid of all the bad stuff
this is kind of the hardest stuff for
people to do get rid of the bad stuff
fried foods processed meats you know
like bacon and ham and hot dogs and
bologna and salami and Pastrami and
pepperoni because they have nitrates in
them which are really really dangerous
things it was actually
the basis of my first scientific
publication
when 500 sheep died in one night okay
because I've been drinking nitrates in
their drinking water for six months the
temperature dropped down to 16 and they
all died a hypothermia because their
thyroids weren't working and that I got
that published as my first scientific
publication okay and it was in a
Veterinary Journal very proud of that
and Marlon Perkins used that
Barry commoner from um the Washington
University in St Louis Missouri
when I was in Africa working on that
white rhino conservation project they
use that paper
um on that mass dial for those 600 or
500 excuse me 500 sheep in one night to
get that Grant that's how we got that
Grant was that paper Okay so very proud
of that okay so not none of the
processed Meats no oils no cooking oils
no salad dressings
um
no glutens no wheat nobody Ryan oats and
then of course because they all have
gluten in them no Wheaton around oats
and no buckwheat because they have fago
Pyrenees f-a-g-o Pyrenees in them worse
than gluten and then they destroy your
intestines so you cannot absorb
efficiently
and then we need to give up
um sugar no sugar that's a bad one and
Sugar's in everything you buy in the
market because people know people like
sweet stuff and so they put sugar in
everything they sell
and so you really got to watch it okay
no sugar no carbonation that includes
no soft drinks that you know are free of
caffeine and sugar okay and also no
carbonated waters okay because they
neutralize stomach acids so you cannot
absorb minerals or digest food
then
um at 178 pounds I wanted to have two
healthy brain and hard packs for months
two Health abandoned heart pasture
months the four wheelers everything
twice a day then
I want them to have let's see here two
bottles a month of our MSM so we take
three breakfasts straight lunch for
dinner time they're going to support and
promote maintenance repair of cartilage
ligaments tendons connectors tissue
discs between vertebrae bone makes you
want to sell I want them also to get the
collagen peptides as collagen cartilage
leaving the tendons connective tissue
from fish poultry sheep and beef
uh scuba that with his morning drinks
whether it's evening drink one more so
to have because of the Halid pressure I
wanted to have two bottles a month of
our ultimate daily classic tapestry at
breakfast street dinner time they'll
support healthy blood pressure and
healthy blood flows through blocked
arteries in the brain and the hearts and
the kidneys But be sure okay don't if
he's on high blood pressure medication
don't cold turkey after medication but
as the blood pressure begins to drop you
can slowly reduce the medication based
on the numbers
then for the PTSD I want them to take
the synaptive take three of those twice
a day that's two bottles a month in the
synaptive
were designed to let the brain cells
talk to each other
okay so they're quite clear what they're
saying to each other I also want them to
eat three eggs twice a day I do that
three eggs twice a soft field to the
soft scrambled butter or just soft
poached soft boiled not hard boiled not
fried okay and then I also wanted to
have the I-26
when we have three a day at lunchtime
not in the morning and evening when
you're getting the eggs but at lunch
time and this is a very unique product
the I-26 it's meant to make the brain
work better and deal with all these
things going on in the brain okay and
um
the interesting thing to me about the
I-26 on our label we put something that
nobody else in the world has done
it says in there on the label of our
I-26
this dose is three chewable tablets we
have the swallow tablets we have the
chewable tablets
um actually
um
provide 25 of your daily requirement of
cholesterol and people go what my doctor
says cholesterol is a killer well
doctors made a terrible mistake over a
hundred years ago when they said
cholesterol was the cause of plaque in
your arteries and plugged arteries no
it's fried foods and oils and stuff like
that because of the plaque and the
plugging of the arteries not cholesterol
cholesterol makes up 25 of your brain
weight 25 percent of your spinal cord
weight
and um needs those eggs needs the
synaptive needs at I-26
and all this other stuff we just talked
about
um what else would you throw in there
what else we just throw in there
well Dr Wallach for the PTSD we have a
product called soul and soul is a drink
mix that just helps to lift the mood
uh which I absolutely love so I'll you
know if I'm having a down day I'll just
throw in some soul I've recommended for
many many people and they are very
thankful how do you spell that s o u l
it's a drink mix so this is smart which
is one of my favorites I don't have a
soul on my desk but it's you just open
it up put it in 16 ounces of water and
enjoy it tastes good gives that instant
feeling that boost
um for those that are needing some more
mental Clarity the smart is really good
for that as well and you can mix them
together
so that's what I would add okay well
there you go that's the program
okay for this guy and we should have
some feedback every couple of weeks and
give us a call
and you know it's a toll-free number so
it just takes a little bit of their time
and people want to hear what's going on
with this guy because this is not an
unusual thing
no it's not and Dr wellick so if he had
been getting up two to three times a
night
what would you recommend because I know
that there are some doctors that will
say well just no salt and that'll help
fix that well they should have their
licenses taken away if they say stuff
like that because saltz has two
essential nutrients but the book is on
your head there's a book and a CD which
yeah there you go which you and Dr
Milano myself have contributed to and on
page Roman numerals six in the front of
the book there's a picture of two skulls
it's one of my favorite pictures the
tops of the skulls have been removed and
you're looking down on the brain and the
top picture has a normal brain and
normal skull you see the skull is only a
quarter of an inch thick the bottom one
you're looking down on the brain and you
see that the skull is an inch and a half
to two inches thick and you can
understand how that would be squeezing
the 12 pairs of cranial nerves and the
spinal cord as they come out of the
tunnels
at the
um
back of the skull for the spinal cord
and the side of the skull when it's for
these 12 pairs of cranial nerves there's
37 different diseases that people get
when they have osteoporosis of the skull
including anxiety and all that kind of
stuff and so that's one of those things
where between the diet getting rid of
the bad stuff taking the good stuff
remember 25 of your brain weight the
myelin the white matter of the brain is
cholesterol you need those eggs you need
the I-26 okay and it doesn't hurt to eat
red meat with fat in it and it's one of
those things where
you got to stay away from the bad stuff
and this my book doctor was cooking
without the bad foods 300 pages of
recipes okay a good cooking and good
recipes
um and so this book has saved so many
lives okay because when you cook badly
and you choose food badly
um that contributes to more problems and
so this book will actually help you
recover extremely quickly if you do not
follow that what's in this book you may
not recover
well and it goes back to the garbage and
garbage out Dr Wallach if you're going
to put garbage in you can't expect to
have a healthy body
and I wanted to also talk a little bit
about you had mentioned the I-26 and
helping with with the brain there is a
connection between the gut and the Brain
when you've got toxins going on and
imbalance going on in your gut
it creates
havoc in the brain and that's one thing
that I love about the I-26 is it
supports a healthy digestive system Dr
Wallach
so anything you want to add to that nope
all right well let's go ahead and go to
the next question Dr Wallach and I have
so many questions that have been
emailed in and folks if you're on live
with us and would like to ask a question
we encourage you to do so Marilyn
go ahead and unmute come online with me
my dear okay I got that on mute down
this time
I just want to say I have a small little
testimonial from a friend of mine
he was uh locked down with covid and
he's a workaholic as far as he works out
in the gym every like at least three
times a week
and he looks great fantastic fantastic
athlete and he started taking the
youngevity product the human growth
complex
and he said within two days he got
strength on every single body movement
when he was exercising he said he
noticed it right away and he orders it
now
like every month
and what I Dr Wallach you can correct me
if I'm wrong
but as far as I know it supplies the
pineal gland with nutrients
and then the pineal gland then releases
melatonin more melatonin as a result and
then the Melatonin will re release more
human growth hormone is that correct
yeah it says pineals like pie like oh
pineal okay
okay and so he's he's thriving he thinks
it's great and but one thing is you have
to take it at night because it makes you
sleepy because it increases your
melatonin
so take it before bedtime
well thanks for sharing sure
yes thank you Marilyn
and for those of you who do not know she
was referring to the product that's
called H period G period H period Youth
Complex now this is not human growth
hormone
but it's the nutrients that support the
body's own ability to make that human
growth hormone amazing product thank you
so much Marilyn
and Ruth Ellen has a question you're
selling go ahead and unmute and come on
live with us I believe Heather is
actually going to ask these same
questions so I'm going to let her do it
okay we have some questions coming in on
Facebook
and the first one is it's actually from
the same person
first one is 78 year old five foot seven
110 pounds has COPD and many strokes up
to pee at night several times on oxygen
to help him breathe that's all the
information we have on that one
okay I have COPD chronic obstructive
pulmonary disease okay gets up multiple
times 90 urinate
um did I miss something many strokes no
mini strokes okay okay well Strokes are
caused by blood clots okay in the brain
and so
um
78 years old 110 pounds this guy needs
to give her all the bad foods Dr Walsh
cooking without the bad foods no fried
foods no processed Meats no oils no
glutens no we burn around oats no
buckwheat no sugar no carbon or drinks
even the diet ones and the
um the carbonated water needs to go and
then 110 pounds you go with one healthy
pain and heart pack per month take a
half a dose of everything at breakfast
half a dose of any dinner time he needs
one bottle of MSM so you take three of
breakfast free at dinner time that's
going to help support and promote
maintenance repair cartilage ligaments
tendons connective tissue discs between
the vertebrae bone reform itself
including the skull and he's getting up
multiple times at night to urinate you
may want to get a hold of that book it's
all in your head and the CD that goes
along with it it's a set that um Dr
Milan and Rebecca and I the three of us
contributed to that set
um and
um one two because there's there's 37
different diseases you can get when you
have osteoporosis as a skull okay and
then let's see here
um the COPD uh
uh again it could be related to the
osteoporosis of the skull or it could be
a separate disease okay in the mini
strokes or deficiencies the omega-3
essential fatty acids which will be in
the
um Health brain and heart pack but I
would get another bottle of efas another
bottle of BFA pluses so you can take
three of each twice a day okay
um because one bottle of each comes with
one of the health abandoned heart pack
but I want to double on that since he's
had several mini strokes he needs more
of the efas and EFA pluses three twice a
day of each one
and then
um
uh as a skull is repaired takes the
pressure off that spinal cord and the
spinal cord has pressure from the skull
it tells urinary bladder to urinate this
happens in women so we know it's not a
prostagland thing because this happens
in women and women do not have prostate
glands well there you go
and so let us know how this goes because
you know this is very common
we do have oxy body if you want to take
a little oxygen supplement you can take
the oxy body but the FAS will also help
with that because it also helps with
asthma and bronchitis and those kinds of
things but this could also be something
due to the osteoporosis of the skull
so back to you Becca
thank you doc I'm sorry back I'm cutting
in on you I got one more real quick
this one is a
um they have vasculitis
and they are 60 years old five foot six
120 pounds do you have any suggestions
on what they should take and there's no
other additional information given
so we don't know if it's male female
no okay
but they have
um blood clots
visculitis yeah vasculitis
okay well again you got to get rid of
the bad stuff 120 pounds none of the bad
things no fried foods no processities no
oils or gluten so we burn around those
so buckwheat no sugar no carbon or
drinks even the diet one's got to go in
the permanent water needs to go then 120
pounds I wanted to have one healthy
brain and heart attack per month the
half of those everything twice a day
uh two canisters of the collagen
peptides so you can take a scuba that in
the morning drink some of the evening
drink one bottle a month to the MS
Samsung take three of those twice a day
and then the ultimate daily plastic
tablets two bottles a month so I can
take three at breakfast three dinner
time they're going to support healthy
blood flow through blocked arteries
and reduce
um uh the risk of blood clots along with
it wouldn't hurt to get another bottle
of efas and EFA plus just think take
three of those twice a day also okay
and so let's go there and um this you
know they need to contact us every
couple weeks and let us know what's
going on or what's not going on
well thank you doc thank you Becca and I
have to say all this social media sites
look amazing and I'm so glad that we're
sharing it with everybody and getting it
out to just the masses because that's
it's what's needed
thank you
yes it is absolutely Heather and thank
you so much for your help with that also
as one of my co-hosts you know it takes
it it takes a team
to build this Dr Wallach as you know
which is why you started youngevity as a
direct sales company because you knew
that product's just sitting on a shelf
we're not going to sell
yeah I knew he had to build an army and
of course being in the military for so
many years retiring as lieutenant
colonel in the Air Force I knew about
building an army I knew what you needed
to do you can't fight a fight with one
person
um you need an army and and you need
various branches of the army because
there's all kinds of things going on so
just one one weapon won't work one piece
of information won't work you need
all kinds of people you need all kinds
of information you need all kinds of
tools in this case the tools include the
supplements
on diets and all that kind of stuff and
so
um the direct marketing thing I actually
went to
um
Michigan okay to one of the biggest
network marketing companies in the world
and spent a couple weeks there learning
how they ran their business and and
actually became one of their
Distributors and learned how to get
information out to the average person so
the average person with no college
education could take the information and
be as effective as a triple PhD with a
medical degree okay and helping people
with their health and that was my goal
well I think that you've been very
successful at that goal Dr Wallach and
we are continuing it for over 27 years
now
and she has 32 years
32 years as fantastic I love it I love
it well I just want to remind everybody
that this program is sponsored by askdoc
no daily with Doc I have too many
websites going on in my head doctor
daily with Doc you can go to
dailywithdoc.com and you'll find a
contact us if you have any questions and
you would like to ask Dr Wallach a
question give us the person that shared
this program with you first and if
there's no one to think use that
contact us option on the website and
make sure that you request your free
15-minute consultation you'll also find
on that program on that website the
store with all the products that Dr
Wallach is recommending and also the
replays from our past programming so
I love the fact Dr Wallach we can take
and put all of these resources in one
spot so people can quickly and easily
find
it's fantastic and be a resource to the
community as well
so I have Annie and Annie has a question
it's in regards to her cat
he's 16 to 17 years old that's
that's he's had a pretty good long life
he's 10 pounds
has lymph lymphoma Dr Wallach in 2019
went through chemo which she thinks
affects his kidneys and they think that
he has chronic kidney disease now recent
diagnosed with hyperthyroidism and seems
to sleep a lot like
uh sleep near the heater and the sun
seems weak recent blood work shows
thyroid of a 5.7 normal is 4.7 or less
and then she pushed some others he has
lost some weight
and the creatine came down as well so I
mean this cat has a lot of things that
are going that are commonly known in
humans is there a link
well
um basically
any vertebrate mammal will can get the
same diseases okay and so it's not
unusual to have cats and dogs and
um raccoons and rats and rabbits and
stuff like that to get human or
human-like diseases okay so it's not Not
Unusual so it uh 16 years old 10 10
pounds
uh this cat needs
a a good brand of commercial cat food I
prefer the canned cat food because it
has the vitamins and minerals in it and
it okay but based on body weight and so
you need to get that I like the raw
Centurion ones myself
and then I also want this cat to have
Orthodox it's a scoop of arthronex for
20 pounds of body weight
but because this cat has all these
problems I would give a half a scoop in
the morning and a half a scoop at night
of the arthroducts the base
is liver and so the cats and dogs love
it okay
also because it has kidney problems
I would take our
ultimate daily classic tablets and give
that cat a half of one of those tablets
a day
okay grind it up in a powder and mix it
in with the arthradex
and that's going to help with kidney
function
okay the ultimate daily classic tablet
so half of one a day grind it up and put
it in the arthradex which is kind of
like
a peanut butter kind of thing okay well
you got to add a little bit of water in
there to make it more pasty like peanut
butter
unless you're adding it to a wet wet cat
food yeah the canned cat food I like
that and of course the thyroid I would
also
um
in the drinking water it wouldn't hurt
in a little you know a little dish of
drinking water put maybe a a teaspoon of
our plant liquid plant minerals uh in
like a an eight ounce glass of water in
that drinking Bowl where the cat's gonna
drink the water get those minerals it
also wouldn't hurt
for that cat
to in addition to that
um let's see here
I would
I would um
let's just go with oh I go with the
um Ocean's gold
um oceans gold to support the thyroid
yes absolutely
and go ahead and grind those up and put
that in with the Arthur decks also you
know just um a half of a tablet
of Ocean's gold
so here's a really good question for you
Dr Wallach because our arthrodex is
amazing but it's not available in all
countries
so what would be a what would be kind of
a substitute for arthrodex I know it
includes the minerals it includes amino
acids
the enzymes
I mean there's so much packed into that
well the only the only thing that you
could take it would come close to
being a substitute would be the hell the
brain and heart pack
so the healthy brain and heart pack that
includes all the 90 essential nutrients
your essential fatty acids
and the ultimate selenium which has all
those five cofactors which is the
biggest hammer in the box that's correct
so if you were to pick one thing
anybody it would be the healthy body
brain and heart pack it is a collection
of five different products but it comes
in a pack and then it has
um a 215 nutrients in it yes so Dr well
like when we're taking that
that whole pack is for somebody a
hundred pounds up to like 145 pounds for
a cat at a 10 pounds or even a small
child
how would you would you just like do a
tenth of that dose and give it to them
yes
and then for like the the selenium where
a regular dose would be three per day or
the efas three per day would you just
give them one then yeah one
okay that's pretty simple
pretty simple
I I think that we try to complicate
things more than they have to be
complicated
well I think what makes it simple is we
we've got a lot of different nutrients
in there it's not like okay we we have
selenium capsules we have calcium
capsules uh we have uh capsules for
collagen we have capsules for this and
capsules for that and all these
different things the 60 different
minerals we have a capsule for each
mineral like zinc and magnesium and
stuff like no no no we put in such a
manner that you know even a six-year-old
will take it okay because we do have it
um they're kids toddy
okay uh and so forth and we have
rebounders four strings which has a
hundred nutrients and we try to make
make it so we're not just selling
vitamin A we're not just selling vitamin
C people say oh yeah I supplement every
day you know what do you take why take
Vitamin C what about the other 89
nutrients oh my doctor said I can get
all that for my food you need to change
doctors quickly
well Dr Wallach I had been taking many
different nutrients you know many of
them are that are in the youngevity
products but they were not in a form
that my body was able to absorb nor did
I have those cofactors
that the body needed in order to
effectively and efficiently absorb them
so that they work together
I was fractionating nutrition
and it didn't work for me
and nutrition will not work for anybody
and this is where doctors make a huge
mistake and of course it all happened at
three o'clock in the afternoon Monday
September 4th 1882 on Pearl Street in
New York City on the bluff overlooking
the construction of Brooklyn Bridge and
it's all documented in this book okay
yep yep oh there you go Hell's Kitchen
because Hell's Kitchen tells a story and
converting from wood ashes and coal
ashes which we had used for fertilizer
in our Gardens and spice in our foods
and we're getting those minerals from
the coal ashes and the wood ashes for
three thousand years
and then overnight when they came out
with electricity suddenly now we didn't
have the wood ashes anymore
and doctors are still saying oh just eat
well you get everything you need no we
had lost our source of minerals and
minerals make up two-thirds of the 90
essential nutrients so doctors have
missed it very badly is because they
don't get any nutritional training in
medical school
their nutritional training is one
sentence
eat well you get everything you need
that's it
well we are here to help educate Dr
Wallach and Ruth Ellen has a question
for you so Ruth Ellen go ahead with your
question really quick before we are I
can't believe the time is already up I
know it went fast okay so I have a
question on Facebook from Margaret
danenberg my sister has been diagnosed
with spinal stenosis in her neck she
weighs 144 pounds
she's five foot seven inches and has
limited funds and just started taking
our MSM Ultra
what do you recommend
okay she'll save a lot of money by
getting rid of all the bad foods bad
foods are expensive no fried foods no
processed meat no oils no gluten so we
burn around notes so sugar no carbon or
drinks
and then
um she needs to get a hold of that book
Dr Walsh cooking without the bad food so
she knows what to eat and then I also
want her at 144 pounds to say I want her
to have one healthy brain and heart pack
per month to have her and that's too
expensive for her she can have one of
our Healthy Start pack okay half a dose
of breakfast half a dozen dinner time
and uh let's see here
because she has a spinal stenosis uh
she's already taken the MSM I would also
throw in
the um let's see here I would also throw
in the collagen peptides okay that'll
help rebuild the skull take the pressure
off this the spinal cord
all right thank you so much Dr Wallach
and I know that you have to get on to
your next program so I would like to add
my co-hosts on here and thank you so
much Dr Wallach thank you everybody he's
with us each and every day Monday
through Friday that is absolutely
fantastic that you are able to take time
to be here for us
and folks
again my name is Becca dukes and as the
co-host or as the hostess of this
program my co-hosts and I
um are here to help
get back to the person that shared this
program with you
um and if there's nobody please please
please don't forget to check out daily
withdoc.com where you'll find all of the
replays for our programming the contact
us for your free 15-minute consultation
and also
the store but get with the person that
shared this program with you because
they cared enough to do so until next
time
bye for now
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]